if this second phase of russia's uh
military campaign in ukraine fails in
the way that the first one did i think
we're looking at a russian defeat in
this war if russia is able to conquer a
significant swathe of the donbass this
will put president zielenski of ukraine
in a really invidious position having to
accept some concessions in order to
bring the fighting to an end
[Music]
russian armed forces are bombarding
ukrainian positions and are looking to
advance from a number of different
directions in an attempt to encircle the
ukrainian front line it's a large ground
defensive across a very long front line
several hundred kilometers stretching
from the north to the south of ukraine
[Music]
in the coming weeks we'll expect to see
the russians attempt to break the
deadlock in the donbass that's existed
for eight years since the first round of
this war began and we're going to see
multiple russian advances for example in
the donetsk region approaching cities
like apdivka and attempting to take
cities like kramatosk and in the
northern lehance region attempting to
approach on cities like severodonietsk
and slobyansk
or russia is really looking to absolve
its woeful military record from the
first phase of the war the ultimate
strategic objective at this moment now
that kiev has fallen outside of russia's
grasp is probably to bisect ukraine to
give the russian forces a really sizable
chunk of the country from which they can
either mount further operations to take
more parts of ukraine or in their
perspective to start to negotiate with
ukrainian authorities from a real
position of strength